this program is brought to you by emory
university good afternoon i want to
welcome you to the first in a series of
three seminars on Creative retirement
and I think the first thing I want to do
is Pat everybody on the back for coming
through the fog the mist which i think
is now rain and the damp to be here and
I can promise you that it will be a full
and stimulating afternoon and we're very
very glad that you're here this event is
the first of a series and many of you
know that and have I think signed up for
the one of three or two of three or all
of them today's event is the culmination
of a work by a lot of different people
and I want to just quickly Thank a group
who have helped to make this possible
the emeritus college had a group a
steering committee to work on this along
with the staff and i'm going to say the
names of the steering committee members
and if you are here i would like for you
to stand the following people were
instrumental professors Bob jahan Joanne
Dalton robbery Andre Ron Frank and rod
hunter and to assist them along the way
of course with the staff of the emeritus
college and typically the staff when I
do this they're never here they're
always outside and I think the same has
happened again al Qaeda registration but
I think each Edwards is here so isha
thank you as well and if you don't know
aisha or charity when you see them i bet
you'll know their names from your email
inbox so indeed to all of you many many
things now
he's going to actually introduce our
speaker today and it's with pleasure
that i will call professor of pastoral
theology emeritus rod hunter to the
podium to announce our speaker thank you
man and good afternoon to everyone it is
a personal honor and a great pleasure to
present our speaker today was also our
discussion leader Professor Richard Ward
Rick as many of us know him as many of
you may know is one of em Rees most
distinguished and beloved emeritus
faculty professor Ward served as
professor of psychiatry in the medical
school for 26 years and since his
retirement in 1986 he has continued his
involvement in his profession and in the
life of this university and in the
emeritus college in a most remarkable
and exemplary fashion professor Ward is
raised in Beirut Lebanon where his
father was a surgeon and a medical
school professor his father's illness
led to the family's return to the US
when Rick was 11 and he was raised for
the remainder of his childhood in
Massachusetts where he later graduated
from the Deerfield Academy in Amherst
College Rick did his basic medical
training at Columbia University Medical
School and went on to specialization in
pediatrics and later also in the child
and adult psychiatry not content with
these challenging specializations Rick
then undertook the arduous long-term
training to become a psychoanalyst at
Columbia and eventually joined the
Columbia psychoanalytic faculty he was
lured to Emory in 1960 where he became
widely recognized as a leader in child
and adult
gayatri Rick served on numerous boards
and committees he was one of the
principal founders of the psychoanalytic
Institute at Emory and he gained the
legendary reputation as a teacher and a
mentor of aspiring young physicians of
analysts many of whom have gone on to
distinguish careers of their own as many
of you know rick is an extraordinary
intellect and a delightful and
thoroughly remarkable human being
insatiable in his passion for learning
he has steadied at least a half a dozen
languages I'm told currently Mandarin
Chinese he has interests that range
widely beyond medicine and psychology
including music politics iran islamic
culture in every aspect of the life of
the mind and of the university and he
continues to maintain a small clinical
practice with his 25 years of Creative
retirement which now nearly equals his
time as an active faculty member at
Emory no one could be better prepared to
reflect more authoritative lior with
greater insight and wisdom on the topic
the psychology of creative transitions
to retirement I only wish to add that
though rick has prepared some insightful
comments copies of which I believe have
been distributed to you in the handout
in the packet that you've received he
envisions this seminar is primarily an
interactive opportunity so Rick were
delighted to have you with us today and
we look forward to an illuminating and
helpful and insightful afternoon
together thank you
well we're going to talk about
retirement as its obligatory these days
for people giving talks especially
medical people to disclose their
financial connections and whatnot so I
want to start out by asserting that I
have no financial relationship with any
rest home retirement community eat
assisted living or the long the life
extension foundation or anything like
that they haven't offered me so much of
a dime to give any kind of talk on their
behalf which only shows their good
judgment but not has already revealed
you know my particular lack of
qualification for this topic unique and
lack of qualification which is that
although I'm now have just joined the
August rapidly growing eight section the
population you know from 9200 is the
rapid most rapidly growing a percentage
of the population and just started to
join that group I'm still not retired so
maybe that either makes me uniquely
unqualified to talk about retirement or
makes me uniquely to qualify uniquely
qualified to talk about it in terms of
the that I'm still facing the decision
now how many of you here are fully
retired and hum where's let me ask how
many are not retired but a contemplating
retirement oh then the majority are in
that category well I'm in that category
too so that's good we can start off on
there do you want to pull in I guess I
don't want to squeeze you with you you
kind of kind of spread out over there
well I want to have a discussion I
wanted to talk and not for me to do all
the talking but way to talk about some
of these issues but no I you don't need
to move that that's all right we're
quite comfortable quite comfortable this
way as you know the whole field of
retirement the whole field of the
activities of the senior citizen part of
our population is in a state of enormous
flux it's not the way it used to be the
big change of course occurred when
Social Security first started and that
created a situation where old people
people who were retired had a source of
income that enabled them to go somewhere
and a live in retirement they did not
necessarily have to live with their
children so there was a booming industry
in Arizona and Florida and other places
for retirement communities and people
went down there and the expectation was
they would they would live for five ten
years that way the children would come
and visit periodically and eventually
you know they would pass on to the
hereafter and and that worked out very
well and that became a great industry
but a lot of problems have developed
about that in the last few years you
know one of them of course is the
looming baby booming population which is
not looming anymore it's here in the
retirement years it started in
retirement years in 2006 so it's very
much with us and this enormous mass of
the population so the proportion between
those working and those a potential
retirement age is changing in a way
that's frightening too I think Social
Security can handle it was going to make
some changes and and of course the
health care of costs of the aging
population are a tremendous source of
concern but at the same time you know
people living longer and people staying
out of the civilities longer has created
a situation where a large part of the
elderly population is quite capable of
work of one so
another and and the and you know it's
easier to work at home these days you
can work for computers the skills that
elderly people have are still needed and
much of our life and so the range of our
range of what you can do in retirement
not necessarily not being retired but
being partially retired working
part-time working at certain kinds of
things that bring satisfaction perhaps
provided you have enough income to
support your retirement maybe you would
want to work and not care so much about
how much you were paid if it was
something that you really felt satisfied
with these things have have expanded to
such an extent that is beyond any of our
comprehension to see the the range of
choices and that kind of makes it more
difficult to a plan of retirement you
have to plan perhaps with the
expectation they may change your plan so
in the course of of time after after you
officially make your retirement but
anyway I don't want to be the one who's
going to be talking well here I would I
would lead off perhaps with with the
first item i put here in the notes which
derives from a friend of mine who had a
recent party was just amazed at how he
was known to be recently retired he was
just amazed at the number of people who
came up to him and said what are you
going to do with all that time
apparently this is a big preoccupation
and anxiety among people who are
contemplating retirement so let me ask
you some of you will you take off on
that subject either do you know what
you're going to do with the time have
you figured all of that out no where are
you in this
this issue what you do with the time
that you used to spend working yes like
four beers what particular things would
be a lot of housing huh but he can't
keep fixing the house for the next 25
years well actually I I'm sort of your
age breakfast ah so you have some work
as it were that you can do well yeah I
think that's going to be much more the
pattern not sitting in a place and
playing golf three times a week I'm
sitting with place in Arizona far from
your home but but actually being
someplace where you can find some other
kind of work part of the time anyone
else anyone have trouble with the time
yes
so
I
I also kept rental property
Johnson you're actively busy
it's nice we're dancing
big active
which would fulfill the generalization I
make that people I guess our type of
people in educational and other work
like that probably our art and I'll be
just occupied after retirement as they
were before her retirement and they do
so many different things maybe more
diversified but it isn't as if they're
sitting around sitting on our hands we
are the people around Emery I guess most
of you here connected one way with mr
main up are not represented the kind of
retargeting the job where they you have
turning your keys and yep transposable a
certain thing and you're not a lot from
the building began after that there are
people whose entire men's like that
they're totally cut off the job they had
before was I cos that's characteristic
of anybody in this room they kind of
leading praise for doesn't come to mind
so total time Phil black and white kind
of the car that's not characteristic of
this population I doubt anyone here has
that kind of funny they don't have
access to friends that yet before they
have just completely shut up yes I am a
question I like a greater studies that
indicate that older people have a
perception of time which time back
faster and / definitely yes it is it
seems to master that's rather as to do
it the questions I had asked the people
who are already required
and what they say well okay this
certainly but no question in fact that
the time seems to pass faster and she
get over and that's true you know all
starts with childhood I remember looking
back at my mother's diary those occasion
when we travel back to match days travel
through Italy and spend some time and in
Venice and then I saw the whole months
in florence in those days florence did
not allow one being trafficked within
the city it really was my carrot which
was interesting when I look at my
mother's battery the time you spent in
batches about loser days time as
melhores a week that's a freak at me was
a total different experience of time the
way a child experiences and the way
adult experiences and ankles on her life
it continues a bachelor back Kentucky
get my agent you say young boy 2010 or
hidden it go tell em I so fast it is a
reason for that well I guess you get at
the etiquettes a something else
I don't give you a word each additional
year is a smaller proportion of the
whole that's what I got that's the
reason yes well I simply think one of
the fact is that might be useful
obsessively with just you know if you're
65 you've got roughly 12 years left and
use that kind of effectiveness that you
know that that's basically what remains
that's close enough there's no question
about come out in a verb
universal currency is I read about Sonny
done a short while ago where they asked
people of all ages to tell them then it
was up and it turns out that it's very
much typing your age as to whether you
think
this way which way to go yeah the older
you are the longer if the longer than it
is because you know it's a minute in 30
seconds well mercifully maybe this elton
at the time does the National we can
tolerate a basis of time we're not
accomplishing very much we're not as
reference of children power demand
activity all the time we're able to
tolerate solitary meditation reflection
so any of you worry about what you're
going to do those are you haven't entire
yeah I retired because my nine year old
mother was rotating through the emory
healthcare system in peabody mother
doesn't care hi yeah so all last year I
was a character
and but but she has since passed and now
maybe I'll go back in the morning so I'm
not sure that that I'm really ready to
retire I felt like it was when you say
really ready to retire what do you
prefer well how do you visualize your
turn you mean from a job you have or
front work from work I mean I would
prefer having a schedule working what
that means within a section up and
working within an organization where you
have obligations to be there in the
morning and I'm so much yeah Hans and
feeling as I said no so what no
breakfast is over and really you don't
you know what you're gonna do next is
I've only had the experience for a
couple of weeks so far but we'll see
some people find that nice at first but
afterward not so bad
so all this you really it doesn't seem
too much of a problem for most of us
most of you though to figure out that
you'll be active your reactive in in
whatever you call the target well one
thing is sure when you retire there's
going to be a change in life there isn't
you your life does change and you don't
have a job you have to go to regular
basis you're not tied to some
organization that Bullock analyst said
you've got to do this from my new vibe
or maybe just have to do this today that
tomorrow I mean a schedule of things
that have to be done when you're not
tied that way then your life does change
and there are multiple aspects for that
change some people find that that that
change it takes them a while to move to
balance that change they go through a
transition dirty before they figure out
how they're gonna force in the lives of
what their goals about thee because
there are now opportunities to do things
that you could do before like by Harvey
for examples
who did and travel around the United
States for three or four years living in
RV parks and a lot of people hobbies and
all that sort of thing so that light was
consumed with his America chetak
existence I think that we can old actor
of all time but I didn't remember
distinctly but the most one guy I met
who always one in spent time in smoke he
loves sailing and and so as soon as he
retired his plan which he cared up was
to take his boat which was more than
something like and connected somewhere
and slowly go down the Inland Waterway
he and his wife living on the boat take
all the time to get to Florida and I saw
them shortly after this adventure and
the one thing they agreed on was they
were never going to do anything so the
whole business of the same since you've
waited to do for retirement I think most
people find is more successful if they
can do some of those things when they're
not retired and not not make it such a
big difference not lay such tremendous
expectations on the enjoyment of
something that you've looked for for a
long time and you know may not and they
end up not being quite the wonderful
thing that you always thought it was
going to be when you didn't have the
time to do it now there are a lot of
other things that change your life
changes a life in the home changes and I
want to direct attention to that as I
said George Weiss wife famously said I
marry George for better for worse but
not for lunch and then that's very true
there's a pattern of change a wife is
not
a constant to have our husband the home
for much of the day this changes
dynamics in the home quite considerable
sorts of late the husband is not going
to be spending a large part of time in a
scene in which he has generally been the
minor partner he's not been he doesn't
run the house and the question comes up
who does run the house you know who owns
US is it jointly owned by two people or
is it from a functional point of view
generally run by the wife and the
husband is a is a tenant at best and if
you take away the husband's office his
sanctuary you know my office is a place
where I can go to my wife doesn't ask
questions about what I'm doing there
basically that's the nest there's a
certain amount of privacy there when you
give up the office then your home full
time either home full timer you're up
doing something but when you come home
your home full time how does this change
the dynamics of the relationship it's
got bound to change or you still have
the same pattern of division of tasks
hustle tennis for example does it still
make sense the wife does almost all
households has when husband is around at
home as much as she is you know a lot of
things have to change and the question
is how do you how do you make the change
in some homes the man literally does not
have a room of his own that's true a lot
of american homes the wife maybe fanatic
about the way she keeps up the house the
way it looks and having a man they're
disturbing and destroying parts of it
you know is maybe something is there
really not very acceptable to you made
your hat
the wife that the man that retired his
first and wife oh these days that
matters is also true then does the
husband begin to take over the household
tasks does the husband plan supper with
his wife himself I mean I know the
husband takes out the garbage and that
sort of thing but what about the other
things and I guess you know from a
psychologist psychiatrist point of view
what is more interesting is not so much
what is a change but how is the change
arrived at is it something that's talked
about is it as something that's
negotiated or is it something that's
left to those subtle of negotiations
that constitute the war between the
sexes how is what they are going to do
together during the week as well as on
the weekend how is that negotiated
that's still the same principle before
as before now you say is complicated by
the fact that in love homes the wife
this is much too brave that ran over as
the husband is so we can't cover all the
different complications if those issues
are not negotiated if those issues make
one of the other person unhappy or
significantly less happy than they could
be that tends to create tension and that
tension may break out in various ways
may not be recognized by the couples
where the tension is coming from well
somebody knows that things are not quite
right actually a marriage change
when retirement is a picture a marriage
has to change and it has to in some
sense be a significantly new marriage a
new contract a new way of really if it
doesn't oh that may be trouble now any
what come on
vanished
retirement or you say you're not retired
but in fact you seem to be letting go of
your main job in Grantville ways so that
it's not a one day you're working a baby
that's correct that's exactly right I
manage my schedule is my patients manage
much better once it's up you find it
about my status is either are you also
reducing then over time he found you
reduced the time that you see patients
over the years say to retire too many
years almost X more true than the
patient's reduce the time over over the
year I didn't take any active steps to
reduce it I didn't take an action steps
to keep keep it up either
recommended we have that option oh I
think if you had the option to retire
gradually yes i think that's that's
because preferable problem is most
people don't have that option sorry say
psychiatrists are unusual and doctors I
don't have I don't have to have a nurse
I don't have to have a secretary I don't
pay a lot of employees I don't have a
big overhead I work pretty lectures I am
a corporation but I'm the only person
the corporation so I can be a bastard as
a corporate the leader and John cotton
serveth as the worker you know and both
of the same person you talk about
workforce changing is there more of a
movement to add an optional to people so
at Emory for example
I doubt if that option is going to
expand in a place like Emery
particularly i know some friends who did
work part-time for a while but i suspect
that was at the need of the university
and was faced out fairly would be phased
out fairly quickly so i don't think they
really had that option because a big
organization like university has a lot
of other things to consider in this i
mean it isn't just a question do we want
sony around said about time i mean there
are slots and there are budgets and they
have to be made up them is pretty
complicated no I think the way in which
it is broader in the general retirement
population is the opportunity of other
kinds of jobs other things other places
where the skills can be used and just
finding out through networking
opportunities that lend themselves to
the interests and skills of the person
now that some groups you MOA like a
police maybe or like the army where
retirement is mandated at a certain
point the question is I mean there's no
option of part-time serving in the army
exactly might be some things put them
and there have been organizations for
example who took retired army personnel
and retrain them as teachers and I
believe that experiment was very
successful and a lot of arm army
personnel became classroom teachers are
very not various kinds of levels and
they just needed a certain amount of
training to equip them for that and then
they found them
doing a kind of work that gave them a
great deal of satisfaction and there
there's more opportunity for full-time
part-time in that service in various
aspects of education so that's what I
had in mind it's a manifold expansion of
various kinds of tasks which lend
themselves to being done on a part-time
basis and lend themselves to be done not
necessarily in the strictly just of live
office setting and that's certainly
which people with skills can content
engine yes on the previous topic of this
newer model where the white continues to
work right and husband as a problem is
there enough experience to know about
the kinds of issues the husband needs to
be aware of if they're going to be in
that situation key issues that are for
making that successful my second
question was on kind of this topic what
do we know about people will be tired
and continue to work for a salary any
part time or do something at a lower
level of intensity but still in a salary
as opposed to those that work perhaps
part-time in community or volunteer here
is and they don't give self is there any
difference in satisfaction as the salary
importantly so those are my two
questions I'm sorry disparity I don't
know that max in the first 1i survey not
at first one's birth with the issues
that are that arise when a wife of jeans
to work and the husband takes over more
and more of a foam roll but I would
think this hand as that is an example in
situation where there needs to be
negotiation of interaction to arrive at
eight what seems to be a neutrally fair
and satisfactory arrangement in the home
and that has to be paid attention to
that it won't solve itself it has to be
pay attention to the purposes and the
needs of the individuals involved and it
would seem they that would not be
quickly settled people wouldn't always
know what they wanted they'd have to
experiment so very premium would be
placed upon flexibility some people are
festivals
but not much with an office well I think
you might have some problems with regard
to the other salary furs to those
working part-time retire there the
salaries important well in our culture
of course salary is one of the main
indications that you worked something
that you count for something that's
where we get most of our affirmation for
at least of our part of our affirmation
in our work life the fact that we need
something to somebody that we're doing
something that's important for other
people there are enough for them to try
to pay for now I'm many volunteer
organizations there isn't a salary but
there is a great effort to create a
feeling that the work is worth something
to create that kind of affirmation how
successful it is I don't know on the
whole I again I haven't had personal
experience with patients who are in that
kind of situation I have some with
patients who did a lot of volunteer work
and but in this instance generally they
had a lot of appreciation because they
brought considerable skills to the
volunteer situation that the
organization would not have had
otherwise and so they got a fair amount
of vaccination poirier back their salary
would be that would require some kind of
study in the month that's best
does anyone know yes I don't know
guessing that you know economics place
of big levels you don't have sufficient
funds oh yeah let do what you want
the notion of civic engagement so
revisiting channel your energy in three
areas that you can relate to that you
believe have social value probably
disqus sad stories as a paycheck I
believe one of ours seminars is going to
be on the financial aspects of
retirement so in a sense I'm not dealing
with that here because its many dealt
with Hill elsewhere but obviously you
know one of the basis of any kind of
succession retirement is having enough
money to live on and not being driven by
the fear of not having a fun to continue
yes I think it's so it's quite a
definition whether you have enough money
to live on and that's how what I'm
talking about right but the time new
york times about a year ago published a
study i'm sure we could look it up that
examined retired people who worked for
money and not the money when they had
the option but satisfaction was much
higher without an income without a sound
with us
I found that extremely striking I think
what it says is when you when the money
is not a factor you pick what you really
really really want to do that's why I
interpreted anyway yeah interpreted also
that you really have a choice to do what
you want to do rather than do something
because that's where the money's I mean
that's the product of problem of people
at work that they often have to work in
a job that really does not bring them
that satisfaction or that actually is
unpleasant in some sorts of ways and
when they retire and they do something
else they can if they're not primarily
dependent upon the money they can do
what would bring themselves satisfaction
like teaching for example for some
people that's a lot of satisfaction and
they're not going to get much money from
it and they'd probably be happier doing
them yes having faced you know man
having his own space is that does that
quiet saying you have a slice of
amazement or something where he keeps
all these tools and computer stuff and
all that kind of stuff so that mean it
is that good for you to keep that kind
of separate space when both home all the
time work is that going to separate you
well I guess you're what you're talking
about can be divided into two things too
many men feel the need to have some
space outside the home that they can
retreat to less or and the other
question is within the home does a man
Joey need to have some place which runs
by his rules rather than by the rules of
the mistress of the household I tend to
feel you know that there was a
psychologist who wrote two men are from
Mars and women are from Venus had a big
thing about men having their own cave
they could retreat you that men needs a
place to go to where they could think
and be free from whatever was the
experiences the nagging interaction with
with a wife who was a critical large
part of time or whatever but anyway they
need to get away now I don't know that
that has been demonstrated on a really
good psychological basis but I tend to
buy into a little bit yeah yeah it goes
I think what Virginia Woolf who wrote a
room of 12 home yeah my wife has a room
where she does her music and computer
things and sometimes I won't see her for
hours at a time I think Esther promote
people yeah I don't think of the house /
miss it I think it's important great for
for each one to add a place in the house
which is their own sanctuary and they
can retreat you and do something they
maybe it's placed with a my wife as a
lake corner she does bobbin lace and
scorn of the basement is her where her
laces and she can be down there for
hours and very happy I have my office
there which is the total mess and but it
had lots of computer equipment in it and
enforced books and all the things that
I'm involved with its projects and she
says it's impossible to vacuum in there
and you know we kind of respect our home
each heroin Eric I think that's
important the other question though does
a man need a place away sanctuary how
many men had that during the time they
were working I mean it could be a person
place a work was not very pleasant place
to be or didn't the Lord very much
individual privacy or it could be they
had an office that I like my office very
much so it's a place I can take a nap in
the among other things if I don't have
something
see it's the place I can certainly read
I don't know that I've ever used it as a
place to retreat from my wife that's but
it is available as a place that's my own
and what she clearly respects she
doesn't object am I going to it and
that's a little closer to what John was
his name was talking about it America
Mars yes conversation of the direction
it is there a correlation between the
quality or in longevity of life it's a
function of whether you are married or
unmarried or single in your lingering oh
there are some correlations there
they're kind of important married he
will live longer there's no question
about that and I think it's especially
true with men but that probably is a
mutual self-help neutral health aspect
of marriage mostly if you talk about the
quality of relationship you know the
interesting of study is the one that I
mentioned in my notes which is that it's
been shown that women who maintains some
degree of close friendships people they
are cut out of a woman that they're
close to tend to do better than women
who dumped that's it health wise long
even longevity interesting enough men
don't work that way you can't show that
effect with men that they maintain close
friendships with other men doesn't seem
to have an effect and marriage doesn't
seem to work either in that sense the
overall longevity thing with marriage
and self-help is clear but the terms of
quality of
so you know you can speculate on well
that's about I can specially I have my
theories of psychiatrist and I think
what's very obviously is that women talk
to each other much more than men do
women communicate more themselves in
their in their relationships not
necessarily between husband and wife you
have some of my wife combines where
there isn't an awful lot of conversation
I they work well together but they don't
really communicate much of those in
ourselves to each other and as for men
we go back to the days what was the
character who had us all being drums in
the forest remember that and write
poetry what yeah well I remember I had a
patient back at that time and a patient
that okay ah and one things he did was
he he belonged to a group of some other
men there were about six and when they
met on a regular basis to as a men's
group it was not really it was not part
of the robert bly thing but he was going
on at the same time and they were
clearly not like the women's group that
we have you know the meat so their
activity as far as I can determine was
almost entirely watching football games
and watching horror movies how much
communication that really would between
them I was never able to discern but
that's what they did but he got a movie
every time when I got together and they
watched a movie or if it was a football
game on they watch the football game
that was the
communication I'm sorry that maybe a
jaundiced way of presenting it but they
sense the way I understood it at the
time so guess that gets down to the
issue of our friendships important in
retirement years do people plan for
friendships in the return when they
decide where they going to retire
they're going to move let's say from
their presence do they think about the
opportunities for maintaining
friendships they have and developing new
friendships maybe that's a pretty
important part of survival in elderly on
is his friendship patterns and
communication with other people at a
colleague back in the days when I was in
cyclic school was somewhat ahead of me
who was the psychiatrist at the Brooklyn
of all persons home it was a Jewish home
and he did psychotherapy in that home
with the LDP inmates and he found that
you know psychotherapy didn't have to be
the way it was in office practice matter
of fact people generally did not sustain
the quarter three quarter of an hour
sessions of that sort of thing when they
were elderly they generally wanted to
talk for 10 or 15 minutes but it was
very important that they have somebody
that they could talk to on a fairly
regular basis for 10 or 15 minutes and
it was it was it had a considerable
effect on their comfort and in living
they were course living in an old
person's home this was not they were not
living with spouses and that sort of
thing but I was impressed by the degree
to which these people needed to talk and
it was difficult for them that should
talk to some of their fellow inmates in
the old person something they needed
some neutral person to talk to to
complain to or just to tell their story
that sort of thing they didn't need a
lot but they needed communication
now a lot of us so you know have a great
part of our friendship patterns are
around our place of work so the question
is when you stop working at that place
do you retain the same friends or do the
friends some change in some dump some of
them turn out to be friends and others
turn out to the people who for whom you
were important while you were working
with them pass because of the work or
perhaps because you had some power in
the organization or what not and they
turn up later not to be interested
particularly in keeping a friendship in
retirement there are often bitter
disappointments of that sort with the
quality of friendships and the quality
of access to friends a general of shirts
tends to show that we have fewer friends
these days that we used to have
generation Foucault used to be of an
average of about four close friends it's
down through something like three that
has something to do with the way in
which we live the way we live separately
that sort of thing and maintaining
friendships takes an effort I mean you
can't maintain a friendship without
investing in the friendships and so when
people don't make that effort the
friends tend to fall off that i would i
would say from psychiatrist point of
view is a serious matter and i'm not so
sure that people always think about it
as seriously as it deserves to be
followed yes
two or three told friends through three
but close friends it is the norm the
best is the number it will be defined as
franta they would say the miserly club I
don't think some some close friend maybe
one or two would be important but I'm
not so sure that we need to have a whole
bunch I would I think the issue is not
so much how many shirt you have or what
you do with them the issue is somebody
whom you talk to you genuinely and
honestly at least part of the time some
of the same of things can be shown to be
accomplished by by memoir writing by
anything that gets a person to put
thoughts and feelings down on paper has
been shown to have some of the same
values it's so it's a way of maintaining
contact with your emotional inner self
and you know unfortunately and of course
there's one of the reasons why
psychiatrists or psychotherapist anyway
exist unfortunately this is not
something maintaining contact with your
inner self is not something we human
beings can do alone that's a bad we need
somebody to interact with that's the way
our emotional system is set up it is
interactive it doesn't operate until
it's stirred into activity by some kind
of interaction with another person
interaction of the dog for some people
that's terribly important but I don't
know that it really gets down to
some things that one needs to get down
to yes the friendship issues is I think
really terribly interesting for
retirement I always thought that really
close friends where people you knew
earlier your life but is make certain
very good friends sometimes in college
sometimes just after but it was seeing
that leads to me and also to my wife to
be more difficult to develop post
friendships as we grow older we have
wider circle in some ways but close
friendship was more difficult but when
the passing things about retirement has
been that it gives you the time to
actually invest in some other people who
might not have known that well before
that's right and as if you're in and you
know there's a meteor problems that
arise one of the problems was a
retirement years is it your friends die
yeah you have a close friend somebody
you've known all your life long and they
develop a cancer and they're gone in the
eurozone then we do you say well on
there being close to anybody again I
mean no that's not life you've got to
have the courage to make new friends and
to open it and find people that you
could own love to spouse noggin versus
the worst nah maybe not horses children
we're gonna make the observation my
is that a retaining
friendships with my colleagues who are
still working it's true that's right
that's why we have your resume our fan
of the work makes it difficult for
people to invest in friendships that was
a surprise to me I thought that I can
have time it would be able to calibrate
your life in fact it's just well unless
I'm not survive my purse the same thing
can happen if you're if you have
children have a sick child is something
aspect with children demands all your
attention that tends to cut down and
your ability to invest in any kind of
friendship was a very very very real
problems yes is it too early to tell if
social networking is having if social
networking is having a positive effect
on relationships among older people I
would think so while they mention
relating to the computer a message
indicating on Twitter for example or
Facebook or just I for me that's an
uncharted area 10 doesn't mean
facebook I'm afraid I don't use it as
much as I should but I have a daughter
does a lot but I don't know that she
would say she she's interested about
friends over them but some people do and
people talk very openly in that
environment what is what I observed and
that maybe seven that emotion that's
what I'm curious I'm curious too well so
it's Benoit right you better my memoirs
are pretty interesting in the past and
traditional societies and village
societies we're often look to
and interacted with a younger people
they were looked at as mentors I just
wondering how much is known about the
importance for older people who have
retired to stay involved with younger
people I here's an important for younger
voters I'm afraid our pattern of living
the past 50 years has located against
that we live separately you know we used
to live more together you can generally
be lived in a city from that what you
might have helped us of your family
around within the block down the block
new your grandmother because she live
somewhere close to you we don't live
close anymore requires a all the wheel
trip to get somewhere or perhaps even go
to a different city that's hard so those
relationships get attenuated by lack of
abuse because it's not much how much you
love your grandmother but how much do
how much you get to interact with it how
much of a real person is she for your
children
related to write that my benefit
who have some distance some experience
is may be non-judgmental oh I think
that's very nice converters colleges
trying to foster these things with top
students and Meredith people in the
relationships of that sort of thing
unfortunately they have and there are
organizations that do this Big Brother
organizations and whatnot and I'm sure
they do a good job it's just that
they're they're kind of running against
this high in our society as a whole
which tends to minimize this kind of
activity and young people a lot of young
people just not interested and people
much open they are and how to haven't
developed the emotional relationships
that makes them loyal to a grandparent
or something and I think that's a very
important part of life I mean there's
some extent when you're an elderly
person one of the things that the
differentiation of young people is that
we tend to see life as a span we tend to
see people as being at a certain stage
of life and we have some of those are
what they're going to be like in other
stages or what they were us and young
people tend to see the world right now
and no concept of they possibly put all
those tattoos on you know how they will
love Albert forever you know when you
know perfectly well they're women year
or so
gonna be involved with it really I don't
understand hey but people do young
people do live with a short horizon it's
a world of what if the council to me
the need to feel needed which i think is
that one of the big things of course
about stepping out of a job he was
something of a job partially is that
you're not as important in my work of
where you work or in the area of your
work as you were before there's no way
that you can retain the substance of
your stature most of us you know we are
identified we're identified by the line
of work I'm a psychiatrist so I mean
that's what that's what I am regarded as
I'm I'm a doctor that's certain line of
work i'm in a certain industry the
health industry and you know our our
society's divided into industries which
are remarkably separate from each other
in the sense that people actually no you
know what do I know about what really
goes on the plumbing industry for
example a banquet what do I know about
what life is like really in the
newspaper ins what do I know I don't
know I know things that are close to my
own industries that were and that's
where I have my contacts and that of
course is one of the reasons why it's
very difficult for people to shift jobs
even when certain skills are needed in
another industry that a person has
plentiful supply would be very desirable
no the problem is how is he fine how do
they find him how does he find
an example of this goes back to the
Second World War which shows how the
ancient I am when the war ended of
course it was an enormous ship building
industry that collapse overnight because
you didn't need all those shifts anymore
and tremendous number of people throw
out of work of the ship the arts the the
highest level of work in the
shipbuilding industry where the guys
were the welders who went down into
difficult places and welded things that
you you had to be a contar gist to get
down there with a will the instruments
and do the welding and these guys were
enormously talented and they were paid
very high salaries because they could do
things that most other people could do
well suddenly there was no need for them
anymore and they were on the line and
nobody realized how valuable they were
well it just turned out that a rather
creative employment psychologists
happened to have a group of people
visiting him from the beer industry and
the beer industry says that the hardest
the hardest kind of workers as they
needed luck well somebody who get down
on the vast and repair leaks and that
sort of thing yeah here was a mate for
her in having combination you know we
take the shipbuilding people around work
take them over the beer industry and all
of a sudden they were very much in
demand and very well paid no that's
worthy our economic life is full of
things like this but we don't know much
about it the trafficking thing I mean
play the deployment agencies these days
don't do very much of anything except
look at what your title is and match it
with some of the title they rarely do
anything more creative than that forget
and you get paid for it and you get
respect for it and your colleagues
around know you as the person who's able
to do this well that collapses when you
leave an organisation like that and then
the issue is how much did you leave that
to sustain your day-to-day self esteem
when you find that you're sitting at
home and nobody really understood what
you did anyway your family doesn't
really understand what kind of skill it
took at work to do what you used to do
nobody around your home understands that
and the only people that would
appreciate that are the people down that
where you work would you travel down
there and they don't have time to see
you then you go back home and you know
and they're they're criticizing you for
having left the beer cup out in the sink
you know instead of washing it out and
that sort of thing and that is the
extent of the kind of acclimation you
get at home it doesn't meet the knee so
a lot of guys collapse in that situation
they begin to things are no good they
begin to sing zaid they're not worth
engine to anybody they begin to be
hypersensitive about hypersensitive
about remarks and where they get down to
the place of work and they find somebody
doesn't really have time to see them and
their feelings are hurt and they'd be in
the thinks of the guy he's down there
all against them you know all this can
evolve into quite a pyramid of emotional
difficulties so you know now let us say
that you happen to be the kind of person
who always thought that he was being
let's say he was acting a little bit of
a fraud they were terribly hard to put
on a good impression and generally
speaking he got by it and and and got a
claim for the things he did but he
always thought there was something
missing in there and the truth of the
matter is that the the actual truth is
somewhere between what he thinks inside
and what people outside think he's
probably does a lot more than he gives
himself credit for but he also
you know works very hard to get a player
now when he stops that process then
where does it leave him all of a sudden
he's back on the original motion which
he was always struggling against that he
had to work extra hard to be accepted
and now he's no longer able to work
extra hard for the kind of actor hard
work he does doesn't really doesn't
produce that result anymore then where
does that leave it that leaves him
really having to confront his basic
views about himself and reset his basic
goals perhaps except the extent of his
success in his profession and lets the
book be closed and say I'm not going to
argue about it not going to claim they
don't appreciate me as I'm not going to
get into that that's what it is and and
I'm going to stick with that and begin
to make to get involved in other
activities that provide a little bit of
affirmation now that's a big
psychological task depending upon how
severe they the problem is that's a big
task and some people will take a long
time before they really cover recover to
forget some kind of balance in that
you've taken away the basic way in which
they've been affirmed and now they got
to find some other kind of confirmation
well within the home let's say they have
worked terribly hard so they haven't
been very much a presence in the home
they hadn't been a big factory David
they accepted being a guest as it were
and maybe over the over the years this
happens with many marriages for example
to get pretty husband and wife get too
involved in the wife on the one hand
rearing children for example or both of
them rearing children and husband in
trying to be success in his business or
maybe they have aged parents since they
have to take care of add to the burden
and they don't have much time to talk to
each other and I remember one couple
that goes back
long time ago at a GLSEN both very
successful people to doctors they
literally had less than five minutes a
day to talk to each other that was that
was a limit of their contact what kind
of relationship survives after many
years of this kind of thing I've people
who were involved very much with their
children very concerned about their
children they cooperate dealing with the
children they're dealing with children
all the time they never go away on a
weekend for wizards treating Sal just
for themselves to have a relationship
between themselves because they're so
worried about the jewelry they've got to
be there over the time I mean this just
takes up the whole life and the question
is once you take away some of that and
you're in retirement what do you have
left in the relationship do you really
know the person that you're married to
it in any deep sense that can be deadly
to the point where it's very hard to
revive maybe it's not reliable they look
at that point people maybe get a divorce
and look for some other kind of some
other relationship or maybe it's a
revival but it's certainly going to take
a lot of work to revive it that happens
a lot
yeah the tyranny of the body as you
gotta pay attention to body as you get
older because it requires it requires
attention don't use it you lose it and
that's all aspects of the body and
that's it discipline and some people
fred has I dissonant some people spend
an enormous amount of time madness but
you've gotta find a way of fitting that
into your life so that the necessary
things you need to do to keep your
physical and mental health together are
done but they're not they're not
I've got an easy answer to that it's
important to do aerobic exercise for a
lot of people walking is probably the
most important thing but there are other
things it's important to do a certain
amount of weight lifting muscles you
know left unused will deteriorate much
faster than we will build up practices
it's a game which the only way to win is
to do something pretty consistently and
that night I guess for the and finally
when you get to my age you gotta worry
about balance and because Falls are
probably the most drastic thing that
happens to a lot of people almost all
peoples I starts in the fall
and you have to worry about balance and
exercises that reinforce models all
those things have to be done so the
trick is how do you how do you motivate
yourself to do that so that comes out
with some degree of consistency and does
actually benefit your body that's a real
conundrum and it's not fun and it's not
easy it's got to be done if you can make
it fun if you have a sport that does a
lot of this for you that's great as long
as you can play the sport and anyway
which you can make it fun with help but
ultimately fund is not the only thing
about it it has to be something
invisible now interestingly enough we
know the physical exercise is necessary
to maintain maintenance of cognitive
that we don't know the cognitive
exercise is necessary for the
maintenance of concrete oh I believe it
is problem is we haven't have a dump we
have can demonstrated regard to Fisk
electricians that actually people's
memory is better people's mental
function is better when they had
adequate aerobic exercise that probably
is because the blood flow
to the brain the other i believe is very
true some people of course invoked the
old nun study you know about Alzheimer's
but the nuns who who studied more and
read more and that sort of thing didn't
get to Alzheimer's their fellow nuns who
were not so intellectually active well
the problem with that was the locus of
the time of study was in the twice and
had him dude o people it had to do with
what they did at the age of teens and
twenties there were more intellectual
than they didn't get as much Alzheimer's
later there was nothing proved about
doing the same thing when you're 60 70
they having any kind of set that one we
think it did we think it does but you
can't prove someone something and New
York Times really recently was at an
article about setting something new
something that was news of the brain as
being a
as being especially stimulating to
keeping the brain alive I like that one
because I was embarking on a really
earnest effort to learn the nuts and
bolts of Chinese characters in a way
that I had never studied before that by
being able to bring them up out of my
memory without any kind of cues that
felt like a new thing and I say hey no I
am stretching a part of my brain there's
evidence different yes York Times also
had talked about bridge as being such a
good activity because of the
intellectually stimulating but also the
social now we have to draw a little line
between go through which we have some
degree of hard evidence and those things
which we think are reasonable and
probable but you know it's very
difficult to prove some of these things
it takes takes very carefully design
studies we just all went through the
great disappointment a few years ago
about vitamin E when everybody thought
that was going to be good for our casino
turns out when it is a really good site
if I can make a plug three years ago I
was solicited and became a volunteer in
the Emory Georgia Tech ticket office to
study and I'm leave last year they
opened up memberships in the am resent
for health discovery to anybody on Ken's
for something like 600 bucks a year big
fan
because waiting for the Emery's center
for health discovery is on fourteenth
floor I think Proper Clause downtown and
they do a massive amount of testing
baseline five functions and then they
assign you a life coach checks up
periodically and accept interval that
you want to hang
one of the things I found at the
beginning was was that my fat to muscle
ratio was far worse than I treat and
and because i'm reporting every two
weeks what I'm doing I'm warning labels
for graduate work well this is a
frightening statistic how fast you lose
it how slowly you get it back loser with
inactivity
justice may want a great advantage in
being retarded that finally have time to
exercise working that should be that
should be but I think important as that
is I think one has to be loose as how
once I've spent expand the time and you
may find made a chart people do just as
busy everywhere it's just it's hard to
fit in
because you have to take advantage of
opportunities that isn't necessarily
going to come almost time as you did
your regular push-ups in the morning are
we rolling outside we have a biscuit
okay
we do want to ask you this by the way
that the importance of a retreat how is
your husband home I can't be here they
use the end of all they work yeah I
think that just has to be something you
think about and you would think within
yourself because they're going to just
go over the flow whatever it will
instead of taking out what we need an
experiment
I
your point is very well
but I
personal circumstances I
enter
and so we've gone through this
the hostages
working as you actually did something
you actually talked about and that's
what I think is necessary whether you
married for 45
is necessary to think about the
changes their impact on the way in which
we live and how should a sec
could you mention difficult some
people find from a retired of losing the
affirmation
respect so tied into their job that's
their source
he said but I heard you say
is attractive to sit back and accept
that your achievements but someone still
tied up in a job in the bay of all the
other issue
she said that
that was hard to close down there they
have bought two they defy other sources
of activation right now one very
important source of fascination is right
with a poem that is whether you're
willing to begin
the important in a different way two
people live home the children may be
gradually or maybe stops or maybe friend
so that some affirmation comes from
personal relationships
they require full step different style
of late no longer the boss
for what
oh do it yourself with a little more
reading Oh deal with that look that's
because thank you much the preceding
program is copyrighted by emory
university